hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show now
i don't know about you but for me when i
try to remember something
i have to go over it multiple times and
whilst there are definitely some things
i don't want to remember from this year
i've realized i covered a lot of topics
in particular longevity research
has been very exciting and that i've
already forgotten about
so i thought in this video i would take
a look back over some of these videos
and kind of bring it all together into
one video
to just briefly summarize everything
that we've covered on this channel
this year now obviously i won't be able
to go into the same amount of detail as
i normally would
but if you want to watch the full length
videos of each of these topics
then you'll find them all in my playlist
hallmarks of aging
for some reason if i tried to link all
of the individual videos in youtube
wouldn't like it
and we don't want to let youtube down
but i have decided to try and separate
this video up
into three different sections that
hopefully groups together
topics into sections that make it easier
to follow
so firstly we'll talk about the research
this year that's helped us to understand
the aging process
and then we'll look at research that has
given us new insights and supplements
and extending health span
and then lastly we'll look at some of
the latest research from this year that
i looked at being able to actually
reverse aging
so firstly then it's research that has
helped us to understand the aging
process better
and so one of the hallmarks of aging is
cellulosin essence
which is of particular interest to
myself since my lab researches it
and there was a really interesting paper
that came out earlier this year
that showed that senescent human
melanocytes drive skin aging
and this was via telomere dysfunction
and so senescent cells can be
characterized by two key characteristics
one of which is cell cycle arrest so the
cells stop dividing
and the second characteristic is the
so-called senescence-associated
secretory phenotype which effectively as
it says
are factors that are secreted by
senescent cells that include
inflammatory factors
that it is thought to help to aid
removal of these senescent cells
so that they can get cleared from the
tissue however if the senescent cells
are not cleared and you end up with this
chronic
secretion of these inflammatory factors
it's the thought that actually this
chronic inflammation could be
deleterious for the tissue and
drive the aging process and so two of
the big questions in the senescent field
are what causes a cell to become
senescent in the first place
and secondly can senecent cells be
selectively killed
and is their removal actually a good
thing and so this first paper i
discussed earlier this year
shows how senescent melanocytes within
the skin
through their sas their secretory
phenotype was driving dna damage in the
telomeres of the surrounding
keratinocytes
and now keratinocytes are the cells
within the skin that are most
proliferative and that help to
regenerate the skin layer
and so this they summarized was thought
to be contributing
to aging of the skin as it may be
contributing to the loss of the
replicative capacity of the
keratinocytes
and so it's not just the skin that you
can find tenescent cells you can also
find senescent cells accumulating with
age within the lung
and also adipose tissue and so the other
major question is
is it beneficial to remove these
senescent cells well this is a question
i addressed earlier this year
where we looked at the study defined p16
high
senescent cell types are indispensable
for male's health span
so in this study they used a clever
genetic approach to remove p16 high
cells
and so p16 is a gene that gets highly
expressed
in senescent cells because it's
important for the cell cycle arrest
however when the team removed these
cells in mice they found that after 12
months the mice were increasingly sick
and had skin ulcerations
and they hypothesized that this is
possibly due to the fact that a lot of
these senescent cells that were getting
cleared were found in the liver
and causing liver fibrosis and so this
did suggest that actually maybe removing
senescent cells isn't a very good idea
however we have to take into account
that this was using a genetic approach
that was specifically targeting
high p16 expressing cells and so this is
very different to
cenolytics such as the satanic and
quercetin that may have different
specificity
for senescent cells and so the key take
homes from this study was that senescent
cells are not all equal and ceneolytics
may have specificity for a specific
subset
and secondly it also raises the
importance of potentially combining
xenolytics
with compounds that could potentially
induce cellular replacement
and to effectively replace the senescent
cells and so this nicely brings me on to
the video i made on unity biotechnology
and their potential synolytic failure
with ubxo101 which they were
administrating to patients with
osteoarthritis of the knee
the aim was to be able to clear
senescent cells that were thought to be
associated with the pain
that patients have when they have
osteoarthritis however in their phase 2
trial
unity biotechnology didn't see
separation of ubxo101 treatment
groups from patients that were given a
placebo at 12 weeks
and so they decided not to advance ub
exo101 to a pivotal study and so in that
video i gave a number of reasons as to
why it may have failed
one of which being the large placebo
effect that they saw but it also maybe
could be due to the fact that they were
removing the senescent cells but not
replacing them
and actually being able to to the
condition and so maybe reversal is
required to alleviate pain and
arthritis and the completely different
analytic approach we saw this year
were cenolitic car t cells and so these
are t
cells that can be redesigned to target
specifically senescent cells
and the way that the authors did this
was first by identifying receptors that
are really highly expressed on senescent
cells that aren't found on normal cells
and the target that they found was the
receptor urakinase type plasminogen
activator receptor
or eupar and so you can redesign t cells
to basically recognize this receptor and
to target the destruction of the
senescent cells
and by using these car t cells in their
mouth models
they could show that these cenolitic car
t cells seem to be effective
and so it could be a good strategy
however the downsides
would be the expense of developing these
car t cells in the first place
and also a lot more work will need to be
done to see if it's safe and effective
in humans
and so now moving on to a slightly
different topic this year we've
uncovered some more information to help
understand the aging process for example
understand why nad plus levels
the key metabolites found within our
cells declines during aging
and so this could be due to either less
nad plus being
generated or more nad plants being
consumed
and there's quite a bit of evidence
supporting the latter for example
an enzyme that uses nad plus cd38
has been shown to increase inactivity
during aging
but what two back-to-back nature papers
showed earlier this year
was to try and understand why cd38
levels were increasing
and what was found was that actually our
lies we're going to cover going back to
senescent cells
was that the sasp of the senescent cells
seemed to be driving this increase in
cd38
activity of macrophages and in the
second study they showed that by
inhibiting
cd38 they could prevent the reduction in
nmn levels and nad plus and so it seems
like the
most optimal solution to being able to
restore nad plus levels
that decline during aging is a
combination of both being able to
increase the supply of nad plus from
precursors but also to try and fix the
sink
and find a way to inhibit the cd38
activity
now also this year we learned a bit more
about nad plus metabolism which is
notorious for being quite complicated
and what was found in this research
study was nrh
known as dihydro nicotinamide is another
precursor
for nad plus and in fact when they gave
nrh to mammalian cells
they found that it seemed to be superior
in terms of increasing nad plus levels
compared to
nr or nmn but most interestingly there
seems to be a parallel pathway
to nr and nmn in terms of being able to
increase nad plus levels
now there's still much work to be done
in terms of understanding this pathway
in particular adenosine kinase is
particularly important
for the conversion of nrh into nad plus
and adenosine kinase is busy trying to
make
atp and so there may be implications as
to boosting this pathway
but as i said there's still much to be
learned about this but it's pretty
interesting
and well definitely makes nat plus
metabolism all the more complicated
but the more interesting and well adding
to that complexity
we also learned this year how nadplus
controls circadian reprogramming
through party nuclear translocation to
counter aging
and so what the study was doing was
trying to understand how nadplus was
actually
regulating the circadian rhythm in
addition to what's already known
as to how the circadian rhythm
influences nad plus
levels throughout the day and so there
seems to be a bi-directional
relationship between nad plus
fluctuations during the day
and circadian reprogramming and so this
really is quite complicated and i can't
really explain it to all here so for
that one
imma take like i would just suggest you
watch the video however work in this
area is super interesting because it
does
seem to suggest that maybe there could
be optimal times in which to take
nad plus supplements to best coordinate
with the circadian rhythm
but again i think this may be something
to look for forward to
more 2021 and beyond but yeah
interesting
anyway the last nad plus related news
worth talking about that came out this
year is the study that looked at nad
plus repletion
being able to rescue female fertility
during reproductive aging
and the major take comes from this study
was basically
suggesting that using nad plus
supplementation to improve fertility
as opposed to using arts so-called
assisted reproductive technologies such
as ivf
and so the difference being that things
like ivf can increase the chances of
fertilization but they don't necessarily
address
the causing problem of the infertility
which could be reduced oversight quality
and so potentially by using nmn as a
precursor as was shown in the study
it could help to enhance the oocyte
quality and hence the fertility rates
however these studies were done in mice
and as the authors say we suggest
supplements should not be taken by women
wishing to become pregnant until further
studies have been completed
to assess whether or not this could
actually be effective for humans
and speaking of supplements and
extending health span we saw earlier
this year a study that showed that
alpha-ketoglutarate a key metabolite
that's involved in a variety of
processes
within a cell was shown to extend
healthspan of both
female and male mice with the reduction
in frailty being more dramatic than the
lifespan extension
and in the study they showed that this
could potentially be mediated through
akg's ability
to reduce chronic inflammation which we
know can drive the aging process
and then a study that came out later
this year used akg in mice as well
to ameliorate age-related osteoporosis
and more importantly they showed that
the way that this was occurring
was through regulating histone
methylations for example they saw that
akg treatment of mesenchymal stem cells
showed a decrease in the levels of
h3k9 trimethylation and h3k27
trimethylation
and these two marks are important for
expression of different genes within a
cell
and so changes in gene expression should
explain the reduced senescence phenotype
seen within these mesenchymal stem cells
and the benefit impact on attenuating
bone loss
and now for a completely different
supplement we've also learnt a bit more
about resveratrol this year from various
different publications
and probably the one that caused the
most distress was this molecular cell
paper
genome-wide screens revealed that
resveratrol induces replicative stress
in human cells
and the reason that's caused some
distress is because resveratrol
is commonly taken as a supplement due to
its potential anti-aging benefits
and this has come from a wealth of
studies that have shown that resveratrol
which targets the cyto insert one that
can activate stress resistance pathways
can extend lifespan in yeast worm and
flies as well as misfired in a high fat
diet
and so in this paper they were trying to
take an unbiased approach to identify
pathways that
are implicated by the addition of
resveratrol and inhibition of dna
replication
and induction of replicative stress
seems to be picked up
however in the study they were using a
much higher concentration
than was used in a previous study that
showed that resveratrol had a genome
protective benefit when you use
satellites
and so i think the taking from this
study is to emphasize
how much more research we still need to
do in order to understand these
different supplements better
and also how important research into the
correct dose is needed as well
and how that could also vary for
different people and so now let's look
at the research that came out this year
that more specifically focused on
reversing aging now first up is a
compound known as
isrib that targets the integrated stress
response pathway
and so israel was used in a recent study
a machine to reverse
age-related memory decline in mice the
rationale behind this mechanism
is partially due to the fact that the
integrated stress response pathway
inhibits protein synthesis and protein
synthesis is required
for long-term memory formation and so
targeting the integrated stress response
could be a viable option
for being able to reverse the loss of
memory that occurs during aging
however i think a lot more work will be
required to really validate these
findings
and to assess the safety however this
year we also had the publication of a
completely different method
to reverse the aging process that came
from the david sinclair lab
whereby they used cellular reprogramming
to restore fission
in old mice the way that they did this
was by injecting
three genes into the mices retina oct4
sox2 and klf4 when the authors damaged
the optic nerve by crushing it
they found that expression of these
three genes could actually regenerate
growth of the axons
preventing the damage in fission and
this was remarkable considering that one
of the first systems to lose
regenerative potential
in aging is the central nervous system
and so hopefully you'll agree that
there's been a lot of really great
research that has come out of 2020
regarding longevity and hopefully that
will continue into 2021 and beyond
now i do realize i haven't covered
everything so let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moments
in terms of longevity research this year
so with that have a great happy new year
see you in 2021 and as always thanks for
listening